welcome to the man of recaps this is
hawkeye the series begins with kate
bishop who was a young girl during the
original avengers movie and had a front
row seat to the battle of new york and
her great view was of a specific avenger
it's hawkeye yes clint barton expert
archer no superpowers but still kicking
alien butt with just a bow and arrow
kate's dad died in the attack so she
dedicates her life to being a superhero
too so now in the presence she's all
grown up and has become an expert archer
with a penchant for getting into trouble
so kate comes home for christmas her
family is stinking rich by the way her
mom's new fiance is jack dukane who
seems like a really nice guy but kate
doesn't trust him and later kate
overhears her mom having a big argument
with jack's uncle armand so she does
some investigating and finds the super
secret vip part of the party it's an
auction for these really rich guys to
buy questionably legal things and they
have some items salvaged from the
destroyed avengers compound like the
sword that hawkeye used during the blip
when he was ronin jack is a huge sword
collector so that's what he's here for
but someone else is busting in now the
ronin ninja suit is there too so kate
puts it on to hide her identity while
she beats up some bad guys as she's
leaving she saves a random dog that got
involved takes it back to her apartment
and feeds it the only food she has
leftover pizza so this becomes pizza dog
meanwhile also in new york for the
holidays is hawkeye clint barton he's
here on vacation with his kids they're
seeing the new steve rogers musical
which is absolutely hilarious but when
he sees someone's running around in his
old ronin suit he's gotta put a stop to
that so he captures this imposter but is
very surprised to find it's a random
young girl and kate bishop is very
surprised to find her favorite hero
hawkeye kate's like oh my god i'm an
archer too take me under your wing i can
be your sidekick but clint's like yo kid
i'm on vacation just give me that suit
back but the tracksuit mafia tracked
kate down so clint's gotta help her
fight him off so in the morning he sends
his kids home daddy's got some business
to take care of but i promise i'll be
home for christmas kate's like alright
now it's time to team up but clint's
like no kid stay out of this i'm just
gonna get the suit clear your name and
go home long story short the ronin
suit's now been picked up by a
firefighter who's into larping yes
live-action role-play so hot guys gotta
fight him in a trial by combat to get
the suit back then he lets himself get
captured and explains kate bishop is not
the real ronin i don't even know her but
just then kate saw he was in trouble and
busts in to rescue him yeah sure looks
like you know each other now this
tracksuit mafia is a hilarious bunch of
bros they're not very threatening mostly
just funny but their leader is not funny
she means business it's maya maya is
deaf and has a prosthetic leg but she
trained her whole life and is a top tier
fighter and she was there one night when
ronin massacred a bunch of the
tracksuits including her father who may
have been a criminal but seemed like a
real great dad and that's why she wants
revenge on ronin so she questions clint
with the help of this hot jon snow
looking guy it's her translator and
cousin qazi he tries to explain that
ronan's already dead you know
metaphorically but she's not buying it
so clint's got to escape and they have a
big fight where she ho knocks his
hearing aid out yes earlier clint
explained that he's mostly lost his
hearing from a lifetime of being too
close to explosions so he encaped escape
in an epic car chase scene where he
can't hear her while he drives kate gets
to use hawkeye's awesome trick arrows
but they're not labeled so it's a
hilarious scene as kate has no idea
what's gonna happen when she fires they
end up on the bridge where hawkeye's
like you'll fire a normal arrow up in
the air then he shoots with a pym
particle arrow oh boom giant arrow blam
so now that they've had an awesome
archer team up hawkeye admits this
girl's kinda cool he gets a new hearing
aid and kate fills him in on her side of
a potentially related conspiracy the
night of the auction kate went to
investigate armand and found him
murdered with a sword she obviously
suspects her mom's sword loving fiance
jack who is a master fencer so she and
clint go to investigate but find jack
waiting for him in fact kate's mom is
home too and is pretty surprised to find
her daughter hanging out with an avenger
eventually though they find out that
jack owns the shell corporation for the
tracksuit mafia so conspiracy's cleared
up he's going to jail meanwhile there's
more bad news turns out what the track
suits were originally trying to steal
from the auction was a watch apparently
that watch holds a secret to our retired
shield agent's secret identity so clint
can't leave town until he gets it back
he's sad he's missing all the
pre-christmas festivities with his
family so kate cheers him up they have
their own christmas party these two
continue to become new best friends he
teaches the trick of how to flick a coin
real good but there's sad times too
clint is still grieving the loss of his
best friend natasha black widow the next
night it's time to steal this watch back
but it's maya who had it she and kate
fight and just then clint's attacked by
some random new girl they have a big
four-way fight what's going on turns out
this new fighter is yelena black widow
sister she's a main character of course
in the black widow movie and you don't
really need to know it but she's really
funny and cool but now hawkeye's like
hey if someone hired a black widow
assassin this has gotten too dangerous
you're fired kid go home but at her home
she finds elena waiting for her these
two have a hilarious girls chat eating
mac and cheese kind of instantly become
best friends but it's awkward because
elena is here to kill hawkeye yeah she
really wants clint dead because she
thinks he killed her sister natasha but
also conveniently someone did just hire
her to assassinate clint but kate's like
look you got it all wrong clint's a
great guy and he and natasha were best
friends whoever hired you look into them
and now clint has to end this and get
home to his family so he arranges a
meeting with maya and shows up in the
ronin suit they have their epic final
fight but it is ronin who wins he
reveals his identity and it's like hey
girl sorry about your dad i don't kill
people normally i was lost back then but
he drops another truth bomb on her he
wasn't there randomly he was tipped off
by her boss now maya doesn't want to
hear it she trips him up and almost
kills him but oh luckily kate followed
him against his orders and these two are
best friends and partners again now who
is this mysterious top crime boss
hawkeye's mentioned him a few times this
season we gotta hope the big guy doesn't
get involved apparently it's maya's
uncle and we've been teased with a
distinctively familiar hand and grunt
and now all the bombshells are dropping
at once because elena found out who
hired her it was kate's mom and who's
this guy in the picture with her that's
him that's the guy i'm worried about
it's kingpin
he's a massive villain from the comics
of course and most recently in the
netflix daredevil show we'll find out
just how much of that story they're
actually bringing back but it is the
same actor which is fantastic because
his kingpin is iconic so kate's mom has
been working for him for years it was
her who killed armand and then had to
frame her fiance jack but now she's like
hey my daughter kate is getting mixed up
in this i can't have her hurt i quit but
you don't just quit on the kingpin
meanwhile maya now knows it was her
uncle who set up her father to be killed
by ronan so she goes to see her uncle
wilson who is hilariously wearing a
hawaiian shirt i assume he's got a luau
christmas party later she pretends
everything's fine and fisk really seems
to love his niece but he knows she knows
it's like i gotta kill so many people
now so at the fancy christmas party kate
confronts her mom but kazzy's here to
assassinate clint and elaine is here to
assassinate clint do kate jumps in the
elevator with her and they have a funny
best friend's non-fight as kate's gotta
stop her from killing her mentor the
entire tracksuit mafia arrives a
battalion of bros but now jack is here
too really was just a good guy and gets
to put his sword skills to use the
shenanigans continue clint ends up in a
christmas tree which kate's gotta knock
over wow and now it's time for their
final stand where hawkeye brought his
new super suit yes all season kate's
been saying he needs a more recognizable
costume and now with help from their
larper friends he's in his classic comic
purple so it's kate bishop and clint
barton team hawkeye for the epic archery
battle they got a ton of really fun
trick arrows culminating with another
pym particle arrow that wow shrinks the
truck uh i hope that's gonna wear off
then it's time for some 1v1s elena still
really wants to kill clint to avenge her
sister but finally at the end she
accepts the truth that natasha
sacrificed herself and so these two are
friends maya fights her cousin kazi
these two love each other they don't
want to kill each other but she has to
then kate's mom oh door ripped right off
the hinges kingpins like i don't accept
your resignation kate's here to protect
her mother but either kingpin's wearing
a bulletproof hawaiian shirt or he's
just that tough yeah this dude is really
strong it's like yo kid don't make me
kill you but kate's not giving up she
does the flick trick with one of his
cufflinks to hit her trick arrows and
boom explodes him even that though he
walks right off but now he's confronted
by maya it's like hey me sorry about
your dad i love my family but it was
just business it'd be crazy to kill him
right after bringing him back but even
he can't survive a bullet to the face or
can he so this whole mess is cleared up
as kate's mom goes to jail and christmas
is saved and most importantly clint
makes it home to his family for
christmas day in fact he brings kate
with him and the dog who they've now
named lucky the mysterious watch turns
out reveals the identity of clint's wife
who was a shield agent back in the day
wow and so hawkeye clint barton has
found his new best friend and protege
kate bishop to potentially one day take
up his mantle and that's where hawkeye
comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member